hey y'all
and welcome back today we're gonna cover
christopher nolan's
tenant and we're gonna break down
whether or not it is is his
worst film as the tomato meter says or
whether it's a general confusing mess
uh we have a few fan shout outs for this
one sebastian moreno
and al also arthur howell thank you for
the suggestion
and i hope you all are well and excited
for this episode i
am although my brain still has not got
my head around what i saw
tennant is rated 70 fresh on the tomato
meter and 76
fresh on the audience score and we have
a super special guest here today who is
with us from
our batman v superman episode mike
kalinowski he's an
actor you can check him out on black
monday jane the virgin
he's also the host of the dc movie news
podcast
and he is a five-time movie trivia
showdown champion and
current in her geekdom division champ
and he's going to give us a quick tease
about
his thoughts on tenent mike
rotten tomatoes what do they say this is
his worst reviewed
film of all time you're insane that's
ridiculous i think people just do that
because they don't understand it
this is i didn't understand my first
time either but i got there i eventually
got there
this is ridiculous i got to defend this
thing come on now
oh come on now
i appreciate your riled up uh in a
moment we're gonna get to chatting about
the movie but
itself and then talk some
behind-the-scenes movie trivia but
first and i do not envy my co-host mr
mark ellis this
for one second but as quickly as you can
without popping a blood vessel please
try to describe
what is tenant about before i do that
jacqueline i'm just going to
preemptively defend myself from the
comments and say folks if you're
listening to us for the first time when
we do a synopsis
it's intended to be a brief overarching
synopsis
and thank god that is the case for this
particular movie because we're going to
take some james bond we're gonna take
some mission impossible
we're gonna take a little bit of time
bandits a dash of source code and some
primer
put it into a vitamix and out comes
tenant john david washington stars as a
guy who we're not really sure
who he's working for but it might
transcend national boundaries because
he's got to stop
a nuclear weapon from detonating but it
could have already gone off or it could
be
going back in time because we're not
necessarily time
traveling in this movie but time can be
inverted in the form of bullets or
weapons or fights or
cars or really anything so if you can
figure out how to invert time and how to
revert time
you might be successful in said mission
star-studded cast christopher nolan top
of his game but was he with tenet
i guess i'm about to answer that jaclyn
wow
that was a good effort you left out so
much
which i think is a good decision on your
part yeah we only got
like two hours so i mean seriously uh
yeah cause it needs a lot more than that
um
real quickly producie lucy how you doing
man i am so great and i
i'm with mike on this episode i watched
it for the first time last night and i
effing loved it oh
i mean everyone's a title to an opinion
even about this movie
uh mike welcome back sir
i'm really excited to have you back i
had so much fun the last time we were
here talking about batman v superman and
i'm gonna
leave those good thoughts to bring me
through what i have a feeling is going
to be something that requires me to get
an excedrin at the end of it because
that's kind of what the
movie left me with but as you've said
rotten tomatoes is wrong i guess
uh but go ahead and break it down a
little bit more uh why
is rotten tomatoes wrong on tenant i
think
from the general consensus is there's
it's too confusing
i think a lot of people and don't get me
wrong when i saw this this was the first
film i saw
in covid where theaters were kind of
opening i had to drive an hour and a
half to see it
uh and i'm not a guy to normally do kind
of things like that but i
i remember i didn't know much about
tenant going into it and then i saw that
one trade uh
they did the prologue and imax before
cove away back down i saw this i was
like i'm on board this is like james
bond
so let's let's go so drive down an hour
and i have to see it
you know i'm all excited it's like me
and my best friend in the theater and
that was it because that was back when
they could have let like two
three people in the theater and that was
it and i remember halfway through the
film i'm looking at him going
i looked over as like three or four
times i have no idea what's going on
it's beautiful
it's cool to look at and it's awesome
the dialogue and the characters are
great but i have no concept of what's
going on
then fast forward you know six months it
comes out on blu-ray
i pick it up i put subtitles on
and it's a different experience like to
to be able to sit there with subtitles
to pause rewind they get like oh
oh that's what's going on so after my
first viewing at home i still didn't
understand the concept of inverted i was
like i don't get how that works
then i had to do a deep dive on the
internet and find out i was like oh
oh okay that's that it's not time travel
it's we're rewinding and it's this and
it's that
so but now that i watch the more and
more i watch it the more and more i fall
in love with i think people watch the
first time couldn't hear half the scenes
didn't understand the inverting like
okay well yeah all right that's that's
rotten
not moving on uh i i love nolan and the
fact that his films
benefit from re-watches they're not just
a one-and-done
you get so much more every film even the
batman films
you you go back you watch them more and
more and i mean i just watched it again
before when i knew i was going to do
this and
there's something called the seder block
i don't know if you know that in the
film the piece of
like concrete with like opera and seder
and
how they all they're palindromes but
they all mix together and they're all
the five different things in the film
i'm like i didn't even get that a year
ago
like here's a year later i'm still
discovering stuff on the film so
i think people need to revisit it at
home and and uh
yeah okay uh mark how about you
where where is rotten tomatoes on this
one well jack i'm glad you asked because
i watched this i had a i had a
false positive with this i had a stop
start with this movie
a few months ago when it was first
available to watch from the comfort of
my home
i put it on and i just wasn't in the
right frame of mind and i'll freely
admit it and
i went to bed i went to bed like 15
minutes and i'm like just not for me
i appreciate everything nolan does i get
excited for his movies i love him as a
filmmaker and i love how much carrie
puts into his movies just can't do
it upon re-watching it for this
show rotten tomatoes is wrong because
this movie deserves better than 70
there is so much in this movie to
sink your teeth into like mike said you
can go back and revisit it time and time
again i did not watch it with subtitles
i had a bunch of friends tell me to it's
just not the way i want to watch a movie
for the first time
but now i do want to get invested i do
want to dive down all those internet
rabbit holes some of which i did this
morning already and so
i am very excited to talk about this
movie
because i feel like there's so much to
unpack and i think that i give it that
above 70 percent nod
simply because the movie itself knows
how confusing it is and even the
characters
sort of wink and nod with the camera
like we know it it's not supposed to
make sense to you right now
just go along for the ride and that's
what i did okay
um yeah i'll be that girl no rotten
tomatoes is wrong because
i have more respect for the audience and
anything
that requires four youtube videos and a
re-watch for me understanding it
means that you hate your audience so
yeah it was great and i am not gonna in
any way shape or form dispel the idea
that there was
brilliant filmmaking that went into
making of this film but it was made with
an
utter disdain for the people that were
watching it
that just really irritates me but
is very indicative of christopher nolan
who is in love with his movies more than
i think he's loved any other person
that's bought a ticket for it
that's why he tried to make people go
buy tickets for it when they really
didn't want to
but that's another conversation for
another day so i will say rotten
tomatoes is wrong
i think that the score is a bit too high
i would put it in the 60 range if you
want to know my personal tomato meter
but i'm in no way gonna deny
that it is next level filmmaking and it
is
something that really pushes the
envelope of what you can do
however it just does so with no care to
the audience that's watching it
like you have to bring your audience
along and if you don't put
enough craftsmanship in that you don't
care about your audience
sorry that's it and so
i i don't in fact i think i agree with
you guys on like oh my god there's so
many things to unravel and there was so
much great acting but
yeah that that that's my opinion um i
know that that
some of my folks on the critical side
agreed with me
and some of the folks on the audience
side agreed with me thus the like
less than stellar rating all the way
around but don't take my word for it
let's go ahead
and talk to our lovely review creation
manager mr tim ryan for my favorite sub
segment two minutes with tim brian cue
the music
[Music]
depending on who you ask tenant is
either immersive or
incomprehensible either you go with it
or you're just baffled
christopher nolan has made ambitious
mind-bending movies before
including memento and inception and the
critics who like this one say it has
many of the director's hallmarks
it's ambitious it's imaginative it's
visually stunning and it's got a
terrific cast
on the other hand many were put off by
its really
really complicated plot and a lot of
them felt it was ultimately
less than meets the eye and that
terrific cast
were given to play kind of
one-dimensional characters tenant is at
70
with 353 reviews and it has a 76
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a fresh review guy lodge
a variety wrote
a concrete cornucopia of global chaos
and threat in which humanity's
survival depends on the minor matter of
reshaping time and space
tenent looks well suited to an anxious
age however in a rotten review michael
phillips of the chicago tribune wrote
i wish tenet exploited its own ideas
more dynamically
no one's a prodigious talent but no
major director i suppose
can avoid going sideways from time to
time the rotten tomatoes critic's
consensus reads
a visually dazzling puzzle for film
lovers to unlock tenets serves up all
the cerebral spectacle
audiences expect from a christopher
nolan production
so that's tenet i hope when you guys are
discussing this movie
you don't lose the plot back to you
folks
wouldn't be hard tim wouldn't be hard
this is uh this is a map with no
destination
but okay there's so much to discuss
with uh this movie there's still
questions
like i said i watched it and i watched
three youtube explainer videos
afterwards and
read like four articles and i still feel
very much like
i get it but i'm still just like why
but hey you know what it's christopher
nolan and that's what he does
so we're just gonna break it down here
brian let's go ahead and do some movie
talk
[Music]
okay so first of all i mean in case you
didn't know spoiler alert but also like
dissection alert so we're gonna have to
like break down so many different things
and some of the scenes it's like well
which version of the scene are we
talking about are we talking about it
from this person's timeline or that
person's timeline from this person's
perspective
is it the time that we did it forward or
the time that we did it backwards
but mike um let's go ahead and start
with you
what are some of your favorite
bewildering mind-numbing
confusing exhilarating scenes that you
liked
uh well one i guess early on is the
breaking into the vault
uh with the whole airplane and they get
the hydrogen in the room and they lose
their breath
and and that whole the whole way that he
crafts
a sequence like that is is
i loved i love that i love the use of
sound in that i love the fact that they
crashed an external airplane
like i i love his his behind the scenes
on his blu-rays are so good because
he's such a filmmaker even though he
pushes the envelope of filmmaking he
loves practical effects he did that on
almost all of his film so to see him
crash a giant plane like that
i love but for me the scene that really
stuck out was the scene where they go to
meet the arms dealer priya and they
think first of all you know they do this
whole great
climbing into the building they're being
slingshotted into the building and then
you know standard spy films we always
notice the hero's got to go and talk to
this arms dealer
and he thinks it's the guy and it's the
woman and he does a great reverse and
she's such a great actress in the scenes
with them
uh you know in in the the he how he
flips the dynamic of the
man-female relationship in a film this
is your operation
masculine front and a man's wall has his
users the dealer you're looking for a
sound resetter
the russian oligarch not personally
made his billions in gas i love that i
love the way that to get out of the
out of it they just got to jump off the
building and to see the behind the
scenes knowing that
john david washington he was like i'm
going to jump off this building right
here with just this rope attached to me
so
again the multiple rewatches for me just
adds so much to that scene it's such a
simple scene and the grand scheme of
this film with people going backwards
and this and that
uh so that simple scenes for me and that
was the one where the film finally
slowed down enough where i was like okay
now i can kind of see what this is and
it's that's where it started to click a
little more for me as far as
what the plot is what they're going for
i guess the mcguffin if you'll call it
the um
the the device the algorithm that they
have to get to that's where it's kind of
first explained we still don't know the
full world
of it uh but for me that that was my
favorite scene that's the one that i
always sticks with me out of that's such
a great kind of craziness
yeah because you're so right that that
is where the movie is
slows down enough to let you at least
catch your breath because watching this
movie the first 20 minutes where we have
this
amazing looking opening scene at this
opera we don't know what's going on
there's a heist of some
sort everybody's uh gassed asleep and
then there's a big explosion and
john david washington's character barely
survives whatever it is and he wakes up
and he's on a boat and we're like what
the hell is going on
it's a lot like your first session with
a personal trainer where you're just
like so out of breath within 10 minutes
you're like
i need a water break and that was the
water break and also
mike you might be with me on this i want
to try that slingshot thing so bad
i want to it's like i'll give you that i
will give you that
i want that to be my my day on the show
wipeout
like that that is what i want to attempt
and i love the christopher nolan movies
give me that because that reminded me of
the dark knight
scene where they're breaking into the
the big hong kong building
but my my favorite scene that one's up
there
jacqueline it's the first time that we
see the time
inversion in a fight sequence where you
don't even even realize it's happening
until halfway through
you have that epic hallway battle where
it's like oh yeah they're going back in
time not forward in time
and you just watch it and you're so
amazed with your eyeballs but you also
your head hurts because you're thinking
about how hard it must have been for
these actors
to do the reverse fighting but they pull
it off
so magnificently that might be the
moment if mike's moment is where the
movie slows down and you can sort of
catch your breath
that was the moment where i said you
know what i no longer need to know
everything about this movie i don't need
to know how a flux capacitor works i
don't want i don't need to know how
these gigawatts make time it become
inverted
all i need to do is go along on this
very fun
surface level spy movie and occasionally
i'll get deep with some of this stuff
and if that's what it looks like
i'm on board for the ride so that's what
really got its claws into me for the
first time you know mark you say
it was great too because i was watching
that i'm like how do they do this and i
just thought well they just reversed the
film
but then seeing behind the scenes they
did the fight like four different ways
like because john david washington is
fighting himself so he had to flip roles
learn the fight the two ways going
forward and the two ways going backwards
and they did it in reverse so
that's incredible to me to watch the
performers do that
why are you here who are you
how'd you know we'd be here
yeah i haven't seen the behind the
scenes footage again this this movie
needs its own movie
for for enjoyment purposes but hey
listen
i will say this uh i think that what
encompasses my
feelings about tenant um really actually
started from the beginning because i'm
actually
a pretty i'd say i'm a pretty good fan
of christopher nolan i don't put him
with the godlike reverence that a lot of
people in the film community do but i
enjoy him as a filmmaker um find him a
little bit to be to be
you know maybe he reads his own press a
bit when it comes to his filmmaking and
i feel like this film is
sort of a testament to that because the
one of the best openings i've ever seen
in the history of filmmaking in my
personal opinion is the opening of the
dark knight
that is just such incredible filmmaking
um and one of the best secretive
expositional scenes i've ever
seen is from the prestige when michael
kane explains
what magic is you know it's the it's the
trick it's the turn and then it's the
prestige and all that anyway
this movie in those particular elements
which played out in two separate scenes
but also in ones
in the opening in two separate moments
but all throughout the opening
he was doing the same thing in both and
at the end of it instead of being
marveled i was so
angry to a certain respect and lost that
i lost
the beauty of the cinema that he created
it's like he created this beautiful
picture and he put it behind a puzzle
box that that takes you four attempts to
solve
and the frustration of solving it
honestly makes me not enjoy the picture
once i got there
if he would have just removed a few
layers i think i would have enjoyed it
much more and the opening
was part of that because the opening had
that inversion you were just literally
thrown into this world you don't know
what's going on but bullets are going
backwards
and that dude just saved your life but
you don't know who that is and people
are changing
and you're trying to throw bombs up here
and there's a second tactical team and i
was okay with all of that
if at the end of it i felt like it was
setting the stage for what the movie was
gonna be you know those
moments like like it did with the dark
knight where you're just like
that's you know i'm the joker like
you're like oh this is the villain and
this is how smart he is and like
i'm in for the ride and with the
prestige you're like this guy's telling
me a trick but like
this later is gonna prove to be the best
bit of exposition
all of that's supposed to be in that
opening and you get none of it
because it takes you the third time of
seeing it before you're even able to
grasp that that's what it was
and it doesn't mean that i didn't get it
this doesn't mean i didn't like it when
i did get it
i just feel and forgive me if i'm saying
this wrong comedy person mike but i
think it's a hat on a hat
i've heard seth meyers talk about this
it's like there's a joke underneath a
joke
and if you just would take the joke off
like it's going to be funny to all the
comedians in the room
but nobody in the audience is going to
get it because it's a hat on a hat
and a teddy bear like that yeah tenant
is a hat on a hat
it's funny it's brilliant but come on
kid it's a hat on a hat on a hat
on a hat on another hat thank you and i
don't need that
and so that's why i'm like brilliant
bully for you
but i don't think you should i don't
think you should do that to your
audience you know who this is going to
you want a billion dollar movie
people aren't that bright that's the big
question with this movie mike is that
is this movie the the super snooty
professor
at some ivy league reunion that is just
talking
mathematical equations and is refusing
to dumb it down
for their audience who wants to listen
who's a fan
but just simply doesn't understand it or
does it do it just enough or do we need
to be dumbed down like that's the big
question because in terms of stand-up
this movie would not work if this was a
stand-up comedy bit because
you have to take you have to lead the
audience with you and this one just
refuses to do that it makes the audience
catch up but i think
it's just that i'm having so much fun
along the way but also the performances
like every time i felt like i was
confused i met a new character
that i was so locked into whether it's
elizabeth debicki or it's kenneth
branagh
or it's robert pattinson kenneth branagh
as the villain in this
was so good i didn't necessarily know
what he was talking about
there was a scene towards the end of the
movie where he's sitting down
with john david washington's character
on on their boat
and they're sort of talking back and
forth and he's just so locked in you can
just see how
menacing and evil but intelligent he is
and it's just such a good performance i
didn't care that i didn't understand
some of what they were saying
yeah i'm of the same way like again i
don't uh i don't
worship at the altar of nolan like a lot
of people do i like his films
uh batman begins probably one of my
favorite films of all time if not
my favorite film uh i find the dark
knight to be
a great film but not a great batman film
so i'm not
everything he does is not golden to me
but i've
people always say they would want him to
do a james bond film and james bond has
influenced so much of his filmmaking i
mean inception is
on his majesty's under majesty's secret
service at the end there like
so this was his james bond film and and
to kind of going with that you know you
have the overarching
uh world domination plot and you've got
the the villain
and his lair and all the attendants uh
if you will of
james bond are in this film so i mean
seder like the one scene he comes down
and meets him and he sees him talk his
wife and he comes up like how would you
like to die
like that's brilliant are you kidding me
like he's
like and then but then you see he's the
villain that you love those villains
because he kind of warms up to him and
he becomes charming and you're just like
but he's
he's a terrible individual he's awful
holding his uh
his wife's uh was his son over him over
for the whole film and like that was the
reason because if you can't if i can't
have you no one's gonna have you like
he's trying to own her and
just to know all of that about him but
and again like
it is it's tough because i hate to use
the term spoon feeding
like he's known for none of his films do
that in it and i don't know if
you know you go into certain filmmakers
films and you expect certain things when
i go to an abrams film i want to see
some lens
flares i got to see them if i don't see
them i'm upset nolan i'm going to go in
and i know i'm not gonna hear a lot of
stuff like that scene on the boat
i had zero clue what's going on i don't
know what's going on with the dialogue
and it's a choice he makes it's a choice
he's a filmmaker that's kind of earned
the right to do that um
so i i do see both sides of the argument
with his filmmaking and like man if you
want the audience to be along for the
ride you've got to make them
be able to go along for the ride with
you just a little bit i'm not
i get it i get that so why didn't it
defend that yeah wait
i will say this it does not mean you
can't like
like add these layers and blend the plot
and do things that are
that are interesting what's what's very
interesting is that
um chris mcquarrie who is the real
reason why the usual suspects is a good
movie
sorry brian singer and has used that
element of burying what he's doing
throughout his story like kaiser soze
was the biggest reveal ever but
throughout the mission impossible series
that he's been a part of
he adds those elements in there you can
do both
you can do both and i and i wondered
about this thinking about like
why this movie was able to
be shot the way that it was shot and
it's to your point it's because
christopher nolan's earned the right to
kind of do what he wants
yeah um and i don't think that is always
a good thing for anyone we all need
editors we all need people
if i need my girlfriend to check me and
be like sis that outfit you thought was
so cute was not
somebody needs to go to nolan and say
this brilliant idea that you have
thought out and and pulled 80 million
different ways
may seem revolutionary to you but it is
confusing to most and tell him that
because i don't think i don't think he
could have lost
the brilliance of it in that like not
everybody liked the end of it
of except of inception but at least i
could follow it through i could
understand what this movie was trying to
achieve
and there are plot holes of plenty i'm
not saying you have to make everything
make sense on a quantum level but you
just have to again have enough respect
for your audience to say
and i know they had to have test
audiences that said this
i have no idea what happened and he like
reads that and it's like yeah well
stupid
bye i think it's it it's such a mix of
audiences that i think
want to that are fans of nolan like i
include myself among them where you want
to give him the benefit of the doubt so
if it's
if it's anybody telling you hey this is
the movie and this is what it is you're
like
okay but if it's christopher nolan you
just it's almost like like when a
when someone really smart says something
says some big word and you don't
understand what the word
is but you but you just go along with it
because well they pulled it off
and so i believe it it's like dennis
miller in the 90s had an hbo show
and he would tell these jokes with these
insane references that nobody got
but it's delivered so well that you just
okay i guess i'm gonna laugh at this
and so i think part of it is that but
the spoon-feeding thing is interesting
because
i i think that i like this movie more
because i've had so many other time
travel movies in my life
that have done it in different ways
where it's so self-explanatory in
something like
bill and ted or a fun adventure like
back to the future those are movies that
you have such a good time watching
that you don't really care about all the
potholes when you really think about
what they're doing to time travel
and then you have other movies like
primer or even like the butterfly effect
to some degree where
you think oh this is really making me
think about what if time travel was real
how would it actually look could it
happen
and so what i will give you jaclyn is
that i don't know that this movie even
with nolan and all of his
creative genius actually settled on what
they wanted this movie
to be on how because there's some scenes
where it feels like they really do want
the audience to to be in on it then
there's other scenes where
again the characters might as well look
at the camera and say hey
don't worry about understanding it just
go along for the ride
yeah and and hey look i i don't want to
take anything away from it i think
there's a scene and i will say scenes
because it's
freaking four different ways but the
scene on the boat
with elizabeth de becky who i think of
anyone i wish would have had
more dimensionality to her character in
this one
it's her um and i think she was
absolutely serving so much through this
story and
and i just wish she had more to do than
be beaten
scared and trying to protect her son i
just wish there was more
to it even though she obviously clearly
had a hero moment at the end
uh but the boat scene and and both
aspects of where she is in the boat
scene versus for the first one when
she's leaving with her son
feeling completely defeated
and manipulated and feeling like she's
never going to escape this machinations
and she sees the woman dive off the boat
with this level of just like
carefreeness and you know and has that
like longing look towards her
versus on the other side when she shoots
the hell out of kenneth branagh
and she has taken that freedom and even
though she is diving
into that water with a level of freedom
you can honestly see on the other side
of it she realizes
there was a cost to this too
look at my eyes
[Music]
despair or anger
[Music]
on the outside
and i personally i i felt like that
scene
was indicative of the i guess if i would
say the things that i didn't get to see
in this one but i
wish i did um i would say that that that
was probably it and again i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna like dissect like it was a
total loss from that one but i really
still love that scene even though i do
think it could have been more
spend a little bit more time on that
nolan instead of
the five-way little roman thing
do you recommend this movie to people
though mike because i like when i watch
movies like this
i think about we just had father's day
so i think about how i would explain
this to my dad or
or how long my dad could have sat in a
theater watching this because my dad
loved the idea of the jason bourne
movies but he just
could not get past like all the close
quarter shaky cam moments he just
couldn't do it
and so i feel like with this he would
just throw his hands up and leave and so
this isn't as easy as saying oh you got
to go see the new mission impossible
movie you got to go see the new james
bond movie it's so much fun
you really have to know who you're
talking to
and give them a level at least of
caution before they walk into this yeah
um
i don't know i don't think i have
recommended to anyone uh
but it's it's kind of like you're a good
friend yeah there's films and that
doesn't mean that i don't love it like
there's films like like um terry gilliam
i don't think i've ever gonna watch one
of his films they're just not for me i
see all the stuff from his films and i'm
like that ain't for me
i'll never see it but people love them
and they're
well well reviewed and people love his
style and who he is
but so for me tenant like i don't know
if i'd go like man you love mission
impossible james bond you're gonna love
tenant
i'm like it's it's i have a weird
love-hate relationship with this movie
because i do
love it so much but i also don't think i
can recommend it to people because i
know it's a
if there's someone in my life that i
know would up i don't know
i don't want to say appreciate it it's
because it's a mixed bag
it's such a it's such a polarizing film
because it's either
i mean and i would say that i think all
of us are actually on the more
um i would say muted reactions to it
because even though i'm giving it the
business here i am in
no way blind like this is just
incomparable next level filmmaking like
just
the idea of like the storyboarding
that had to be done to plot out this
plot
is probably more complicated than a and
then academy award-winning filmmakers
that we know and love are capable of
and they would have to think on this
movie for a decade
just to give it a passable effort to
what christopher nolan was able to do in
just a handful of years so i
i don't want to diminish that but i also
can't sit here and pretend
that again it's a puzzle box and i'm not
exactly sure if underneath it once you
line everything up
and it's almost like you took a basic
really basic story
with pretty basic characters and you
just jumbled it up in enough
mix to where you could give it more
complexity because i've heard a lot of
people say that this is a stupid smart
person
movie that's hilarious yeah but i mean
because one of the things that i did
feel occasionally watching this movie
is i felt like the the little kid at
christmas who opened something and is so
young that you don't really understand
the actual toy you got but you like
playing with the big box
and the big box in this movie is the
performances for me because
everybody is just so good as their
character
and and that's what i said that kept
stringing me along and so when i'm
asking myself questions about wait a
minute so
who is is is john david washington's
character actually
yeah because then robert pattinson shows
up and he's great
and elizabeth de becky shows up and all
these
all these great performers they just
i that was one of the selling points of
this movie to me if they didn't fully
commit to what they were doing
and it and and at times a lot of them
are bewildered
by the science of it and so at least
even though i didn't understand
most of the science i could at least
relate to some of the characters because
i knew they didn't understand what was
going on either
they just had to go along for the ride
and sort of put their faith in whatever
this
time inversion process was can i just
ask this though
first time christopher nolan has
a non-white british guy in the lead not
really but close
and he makes him literally the most
uninteresting character until the last
frame of the film
just gonna say that he was not
look again he's not interesting the hot
sauce line was great
he didn't think of that that was not
christopher nolan let me just put it
this way
robert pattinson throughout the movie
you're like okay i don't know what's
going on with this guy he's got a little
bit more going on and
give it up for kenneth branagh he has
given you boris and natasha realness
like give it up good forth you know what
i mean yeah exactly
like that's fine but john david
washington feels like a guy that is
luggage in his own story where he is
called the protagonist
and until the end where you realize he's
not the luggage that he's actually the
conveyor belt that's put all this stuff
together
but again you don't get that into the
last shot of the movie when he kills the
indian lady
see like i i disagree because for me
with john david washington like i knew
he was in black klansmen but he didn't
stand out in that there were so many
more
like more people's chewing scenery and
and bigger personalities in that film
where he kind of took a
that didn't take a backseat but he was
kind of more the straight guy through it
this film to me i watched it as like
this guy's a movie star this guy
he just there's this charisma about him
that he exudes because it was so subtle
he was so
subtle and laid back and the way he he
was in the every scene
and just seeing him next to elizabeth
tobey i know she's very tall but he
seems very short to it like that
throughout the film he just had this big
presence the whole time
and at the end of it like that was like
i want to see this character again i
want to see more adventures with the
protagonist with this guy because
this was the film and i'd seen uh him
before and other stuff but this is the
film that's like okay i really like him
as an actor
uh but again like i guess thinking back
to the film
uh in that one scene with barbara it was
a clemens posey
who was it was kind of funny he's like
oh that's flora delacroix from the harry
potter films she shows up and she's like
hey
don't understand it just go along with
it she even like they wrote that in
there they're just like
just go along you're not gonna
understand it just go with it and i'm
like okay that was
that was a line from the studio that
they're like the test
is just gonna ask can we just get
somebody to say
this in the movie because we need to
because people are pissed off
can we also bring up speaking of lines
jacqueline producer lucy here
um it went back to john david washington
when he goes
mission accomplished at the end i was
like oh that's
that's the one cringy moment for me
i mean i'm glad you made it that far
yeah i will say
um what's her name's hair game the
indian lady
uh i was like all about the the
the gray realness like like salt and
pepper thing she had going i was like i
just want your outfits
and your hair style and like every
costumes
across the board in this the only thing
i knew about the movie before i watched
it was that there was fashion and we
brought the fashion
oh it's so good i every suit that he's
wearing i'm like yeah
i want to try that on like i want to
look that good and even the scene where
he meets michael caine because it's
christopher holden you know you're going
to get a great michael caine scene
he walks in and and i'm i'm thinking in
my head like how good
jdw looks in this suit and then michael
caine is like that brooks brothers and
i'm like oh
i thought it looked nice i thought you
looked fine there's nicer suits than
brooks brothers what
i i i'm not going to lie to you he looks
uh
yeah he looks good he looks good in
everything that he does now john david
washington looks good de becky
was made to model clothes in her dna
um but even like the side characters
kane shows up tailored
tailored yeah one thing i understand
with the clothes maybe you guys can
understand this i don't get his look
with the polo shirt with the button all
the way to the top
i don't get that like i've never gotten
that in life i'm like
what is that choice mike you're a very
stylish dude
mostly with capes somebody needs to gift
you some gq sir
yeah but i've worn polos i don't wear
them buttoned to the top like that you
need to read this
it's in it's in the fashion now michael
kaine says you got to wear the polo
shirt or the button all the way to the
top
and that way they'll know that you're a
true rich man it's it's what they
actually i've learned this because by
the way i was the girl that wore
my uniform from age 12 to age
35 was black jeans nerd shirt
black sweater that was it and that's
your outfit
all i had and then i got this damn job
and they
introduced me to people they introduced
me to the s word
stylist and that's with the button you
know what it is it's called
xing it's the little touchscreen yeah
that's what i did
that's what that's what nikki taught me
that yes thank you
shout out to our mutual uh archie
stylist nikki who like gets us set up
when we go to like events and shows
when you roll your sleeves about judging
the top button
no it is and that's what it is and it's
the little details
that can show somebody that this outfit
was thoughtful whether it be an added
accessory or like the way that you
wear the shirt it's literally stupid
stuff like that i did not think we were
gonna go into a whole
um
what was the name of project runway i
didn't know we're going to have a
project runway sort of detour
but um let's bring it back to the to the
moment at hand and
one thing i will talk about i think
we've talked about the characters i
don't think anybody didn't give it their
all
i would just also say i do think that
john david washington was the least
interesting
person in this whole movie until the end
and i will stand by that i think
yeah i think two hours and 20 minutes of
the movie you might have a point but
every so
often he does have some some comedic
moment or some
persona charisma moment that it gets me
through it's just
enough catnip to get me to the next
scene because he is focused on the
mission but there is a personality there
and and i like that it was hidden below
the surface
and i will also add the most least the
the least interesting person in a
christopher nolan movie
still has more style substance and stuff
going on than most movies
put together um this is kind of like
more like
like not so much movie specific talk but
some other stuff but
the the thing that always gets talked
about and we've already alluded to it a
little bit is christopher nolan
and his sound choices as it were
and like where and what he chooses to do
with all that
i guess because i was at home and i was
watching it with headphones
um you can't mess with me i had
captioning
i watched it with headphones but i do
feel for people that had to see this in
a movie theater
i don't yeah mike can speak to that
better than i can because i didn't see
this in a theater and i
i didn't even notice any issues with the
sound watching it on
on my tv i mean i have a nice like the
sound system but i wasn't wearing
headphones did not have the subtitles on
and i
i was still pretty good i never really
picked up on any sound issues
yeah i i and nolan again he is so much
of a proponent
of all his films when he goes like
making sure the theaters have the right
sound settings and
i remember before this film came out and
before cove it happened it's kind of
like i think it was
january february last year i was walking
into universal studios
to go to work and i saw nolan coming out
of the amc imax because that's like the
only true imax in burbank
and i saw him he had his kind of little
entourage with him and
i'm sure he was there probably either
seeing a cut of it or checking the sound
or whatever because he's so much
involved in
it i mean it speaks to him as a
filmmaker where every detail of a film
the attention to detail that he puts
into it like we saw we talked about
costumes like every little
level he doesn't skimp on it doesn't go
well you know
that's just sound or that's just a
costume design everyone
everything gets the equal focus that the
acting and the story does
but there are scenes like the boat scene
i mentioned where it's just like that
was the time i leaned over to my buddy
i'm like i don't know what's going on
what is he saying here
like i got the whole bane thing and i
got what that was coming from
you know there was a reason story went
behind it but this film
and i don't know that why i mean the
whole car chased backwards
accidents crashed i understood
everything then and you would think
because the sound of everything
they would want to jumble if you wanted
to create kind of a real world whatever
but that boat scene
i didn't had no clue what's going on
until i watched it with closing foley is
more important to him
like he's somebody who actually probably
is best friends with this foley artist
and you know what i mean like he wants
that dude to shine
i think it's funny that you mentioned
you saw nolan at the amc i don't know if
this was this case
but when they were making the case when
tenant hint theaters in the united
states and they were like you were it's
only going to be here and blah blah blah
blah
he actually did buy a ticket to go see
it and he wanted to like show people but
i don't know if that was when you saw
him but i do remember he made a big deal
of like they filmed it
actually of him being at the theater uh
going to see it in imax and like it was
him
and the president of amc and like a head
person from warner brothers like
doing this as a thing but that was what
he did
with the execs right i heard a story and
this was
published so i'm not like talking tales
out of school but edgar wright talked
about
the reason why he was able to get mary
elizabeth winstead for scott pilgrim
is that when grindhouse came out quentin
tarantino
was doing a q a at the arcolite
and he was meeting edgar for that one
and mary elizabeth winstead was there
and he made them all drive around to the
various movie theaters because he's like
yeah but i want to see what the crowd at
the vista
um is like when they watch it and then i
want to go see the crowd at this theater
to see how they react to it
because for quentin it was all about in
the theater
what were these people feeling and he
knew that there was a difference
audience that was going to be seeing it
at the vista versus the arcolite versus
the landmark and nolan only cares about
the sound that the imax in dolby
two types of filmmakers that's all i
will say not saying either one of them
don't have this
don't have egos the size of texas but
what they care about may be different
i don't know i'm not saying quinton
doesn't care about the sound but it
feels like the sound is
nolan's best best friend that's me mark
that's fair i i mean i again i didn't
pick up any
any issues with it on my end but i do
know how much carrie puts into
every every facet of his movie which is
why even though again i wouldn't
consider myself worshiping at his altar
i think these are sort of movies that i
that i do feel like are events because
it's not just the filmmaking
itself but it's the roll out it's how he
he crafts his trailers how he has
oversight over all these things
leading up to the movie where you do
feel like it's a big event so even if
the movie doesn't wow me
the first time i see it like
interstellar like when i tried to watch
tenna for the first time
i it's i i at least give it the the
credibility that maybe it was on me
and not on the movie that i need to go
back and do some revisiting and
investigation so i'm glad we did this
episode because
it got me to actually sit down and watch
tenant and i found it a rewarding
experience do you guys feel that with
tenant because of
uh nolan the films that we we came to
expect like momento
and then uh because i remember when
inception was coming out there was so
much hype for this film because you go
in
and i guess that's kind of what m night
challenge used to have with the twist
and turn you you're like i'm gonna be
wowed by this guy
like dunkirk for me didn't have this
with nolan like i didn't feel everyone
was like i gotta see dunkirk that seemed
like his most kind of straightforward
film
that he's done in a while whereas this
phone comes out and everyone's like oh
it's bad it's old school nolan again
it's it's the inception nolan it's the
prestige nolan
and then there wasn't exactly like it
was the least possibly
yeah yeah there wasn't the reveal like
you'd said like
that like ah that was it like the other
films have had a much cleaner reveal
and a much cleaner like like prestige
you see like that's it
we get it yeah yeah that turn happens
you're like i get it
with tenant you're kind of like a year
later you're like did i get the turn
or am i unwrapping another is it like
the little russian doll where you open
it like
oh there's another one and there's
another what am i doing so then there's
maybe this isn't
it it's just a little kenneth branagh
just yeah
y'all are gonna have to like uh bleep
that in russian because i told i stole
that from katya and rupaul's drag race
and my streak for adding drag race to
this podcast
continues anyway listen i will add this
because this was a two and a half hour
movie and so i do not in any way saying
that we should have made this longer but
do y'all think this would have been
better
as an episodic it's tough to get me
to come back week after week if i don't
understand something that much oh
lost ratings belies that mark
that's a good point though because it it
because ross was really good at the
cliffhangers
like and you're like oh now i gotta come
back i gotta see what's in the hatch i
gotta see what the polar bears or the
smoke monster is about
this i probably would but i i don't know
you know me jacqueline i get very
excited about a tv
show for three weeks and then i just
completely fall off the face of the
earth with it so i don't know that i
would have hung in
with tana the whole time i think i like
this as a motion picture
hey and i will let you have the last
word on that
uh because we got to move on to trivia
because again we
literally did again this movie i will
give it this you can talk a lot about
it we can talk a lot about it but
let's go ahead and take it to behind the
scenes all right brian
q
[Music]
mark sir what do you got for us and i am
perfectly comfortable with the fact that
i'm likely gonna lose so
let's just get this over with yeah i
mean you got no slouch
as far as trivia goes next to you there
but we're gonna go a little light
on on the the nolan batman movies
um simply because i know as much as mike
probably wants to read this attendant
again and again
he's never going to see his movies as
much as he studies the the batman
movies um your first trivia question is
for both of you why is the dark knight
rises so bad no i'm kidding it's a joke
um i'm like do not open this up again
that was me that was just me
my personal issues i apologize to our
audience so
here is your very first trivia question
and that is
i need you to just both y'all to just
guess and whoever gets closest wins
as far as christopher nolan's average
tomato meter score
for all of his films take all
christopher nolan's movies what is his
average tomato meter score 88.
oh it's jaclyn's guess and mike
kalanowski i was gonna
my gut right off the bat was 87. all
right you one dollared her
and it's gonna pay dividends because the
answer is 84 percent
hey i watched a lot of prices right hey
hey we both would have been over but i
guess you're still closest
and then we got two more questions can
you answer
this one what is his highest rated movie
on the tomato meter
his highest greatest movie i'm just
gonna say my favorite and it's not gonna
be that one but i'm gonna go ahead and
say the prestige
and mike uh i'll say the dark knight all
right i am with mike because i do
think batman begins is the best of those
movies might be my favorite
comic book movie ever yes it is the dark
knight is the highest
on the tomato meter but the prestige is
super fresh it's certified fresh as well
and it's also really awesome so i'll
give you that jaclyn the final
actually i do have one more that it's
just gonna be fun to mess with y'all
so okay i'm gonna give you all each 10
seconds or less and you have to explain
time inversion to me and done
okay mike 10 seconds or less 10 seconds
on the clock explain me time inversion
go
it's the object is hit with the
radiation and
is then doing its life backwards
that's not bad that is but i don't know
where the radiation comes from
i don't know i know a scientist created
radiation that it radiates
and then they built the algorithm which
was a device that was going to make the
entire world go backwards essentially
killing itself i've used the word
algorithm before
in in everyday talk but every time
somebody says it to me i go right back
to
calculus and my my eyes just roll in the
back of my head
and all feeling glazes over my body i
always thought i don't know why i was
always calling in a logarithm a lot i
don't know why i call it that
i have to consciously go algorithm
i have to do that with pro with probably
i because i was
because i had trouble spelling when i
was a kid i used to say probably and so
sometimes i will say probably
because that's how i learned how to
spell it
as an adult yeah because you can just
say uh
um and that is the time inverted way to
say
algorithm okay your final question and
this is one that maybe you know it or
you don't mike might have a leg up
because he is such a huge james bond
honk oh no
this like we said is sort of christopher
nolan paying homage in a way to a lot of
movies but particularly the world of
james bond
what was the first james bond film that
christopher nolan saw
in a movie theater moonraker just
because i have nothing
my gut is saying under her majesty's
secret service
all right the answer the spy who
loved him
both of you one of you went lazande one
of you want more
but the answer was the spy who loved me
and that is
your christopher nolan slash tenant
trivia questions and man
did i go easy on you all because given
the subject matter of this movie
i could ask you all stuff that i didn't
have the answer to
and honestly i would have been very fine
with it because again it hurts my head
as far as we go and i need a little bit
of an aspirin so we're going to go ahead
and go to the mailbag which is going to
give it to me
brian cues music
all right here we go from a member of
the ketchup crew
grace aslan sorry grace if i got that
wrong but your name is awesome so hello
i know the lion the line i like that
that's how i'm saying it yeah i'm gonna
think you're probably right hello my
name is grace i would love it
if you guys oh sorry i would love it for
you guys to discuss
wayne's world i believe it deserves a
way higher than a meager 78
as it is one of my favorite movies of
all time i would love to hear your
discussion on the jokes
whether it is held up through the years
thanks for reading this and i look
forward to your next episode grace
i think you may be in luck man also i'm
a fan of the sequel
like i've been known for this i've been
known for this to be a fan of the sequel
and again we will i still am waiting on
our
mortal kombat annihilation episode
because i know i'm like one of one i
know one other person who enjoys it
you enjoy that movie i really do but i
enjoy it the way you enjoy the room
yeah like i do not enjoy it like and now
you lose i'm sorry when she says that
i am done i'll go back and watch it with
with those kind of glasses with the room
colored glasses on but as far as we can
do that with that with that film
i mean they're totally in with with
grace's pick but yes i would like to
have a companion piece for wayne's world
too because i think there's maybe
three comedies in my estimation beverly
hills cop2 is more of an action comedy
three comedies that
have superseded the original and that
would be uh beverly hills cop two
naked gun two and a half and wayne's
world two it is almost impossible to
make the comedy sequel funnier than the
original
i think those all managed to pull it off
but the original wayne's world
is uh is definitely fresh grace i with
you
i'm also a pretty big fan of bad boys
too mostly for the scene when they meet
mark lawrence's uh daughter's boyfriend
that is gold right there dan marino's
great in that movie
[Laughter]
you're so ridiculous all right um
mike thank you so much this was a blast
yet again i appreciate you for being
such a good sport uh with my deadpan not
liking of this one but
you actually you warmed me up a little
bit more i will say that so
um as part and gift why don't you tell
folks what you're working on and where
they can find you
uh you can find me uh at twitter and on
my youtube channel at mike kalinowski i
have a
uh a book that i'm working on i can't
say it yet i'm still kind of
under not an nda on it but it's not
ready to be announced yet but it's a
book
releasing this fall that i've been
working on i got it happened during
quarantine
um with the publisher and and uh i've
been working on that so
hopefully i'll have more to tell soon so
i will absolutely put that out there on
my
facebook on my instagram page and my
twitter at mike kalinowski so that's
what i'm working on right now i
host dc movie news we've been on hiatus
ever since quarantine
because we filmed in studio and we never
really got up to the zoom thing we kind
of do
random things when a big movie premieres
but we're really trying to work to get
that
podcast back up and running uh for
everybody so is it going to be easier
for me to watch tenant and understand it
or to read your book
read my book my book okay yeah he's
literate
come on now mark let's give the man
something i'm just making sure
but i'm making my book designed so you
can read it backwards and forwards and
it's like oh
my gosh basically mark is saying
if it's not if it's not the history of
espn
it's gonna be a stretch for him so i'm
glad that you're making it you're making
it mark ella's success
it's literally the book that's in the
bathroom right now is those guys have
all the fun it's the story of espn it's
30 for 30 on
uh tennant and nolan i love it um also
uh mike since you watch things and know
more about them the most
uh give us a recommendation oh you know
what it came out a little while ago but
i caught up during quarantine's
chernobyl
go and watch this tv series like i
didn't catch it when it first came out
watching that during the pandemic seeing
how russia acted and then seeing our
country over the past year
the parallels are staggering to how
people react and
it's go and watch that film right that
tv series right now with what we've just
been through it's insane
chernobyl i'm a fan of him as a writer
he's also great
he's also a great twitter follower so
that's a great one i i
agree with you uh on that one as
yeah i gotta do it i gotta check it out
i'll get around to doing it
it's five episodes five or six real
quick as a count as a as a
pairing you should watch the liam neeson
harrison ford
k19 the widowmaker k9 the widowmaker
movie where they have the worst russian
accents
in the world but the
radi there's the radiation scene and
it's very
similar to all the horrific crap that
happens in chernobyl
yeah but i will say if they had cast
kenneth branagh
they would have been a better russian
accent because he i mean
tell me how you want to die a little bit
would you like me to slit your throat
and put your
if we're gonna go russian give me john
malkovich and rounders
that's me do splash the pot i splash the
pot
yeah he's got the oreos like boris
and all of our russian listeners are
like unsubscribe
please please don't i'm joking i'm so
kidding
and please do stay subscribed to us
please also follow rate
subscribe wherever you're able to on
whatever platform and email us here at
the show
rt is wrong at rotten tomatoes we want
to hear from you
give us recommendations let us know if
you are a member of the ketchup crew and
how many people you have indoctrinated
into our calling all right mark next
week
we're going to save the world yet again
right you know jacqueline i could stay
awake just to hear
you're breathing it's armageddon that
sounds so creepy
i know i know i'm not stephen tyler
but uh yeah we are gonna be talking
about armageddon
uh we do not want you to miss a thing so
make sure that you do all the stuff that
jacqueline asked you to do with the
podcast and come on back next week when
we talk about
saving the world michael bay's style it
may not be
the filmmaking achievement that tenet
was but at least we understood the
premise
we got to send a bunch of oil drillers
to go blow up a giant rock
because lord knows we couldn't train
spacemen
to do that all right we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you